five at eleven
this is eight news now
airports expect to be busier this summer
than they have been in years and
airlines will have to handle the load
with a shortage of pilots over the next
decade more than fourteen thousand
openings are projected each year but the
pandemic slowed the rate of newly minted
pilots with only forty three hundred
graduating in twenty twenty one at the
same time older pilots accepted covid
era buyouts further thinning the ranks
now because of that airlines are hiring
at the highest rate in decades and with
the demand for new pilots a chance to
fill the gap with more women kirsten
joyce recently connected with a mother
from boulder city and shares her pursuit
of the stream and the flight school
helping her achieve it
i remember my first time sitting up in
the cockpit of an md-80. that's when 28
year old daniel fry knew she wanted to
become a pilot her journey with aviation
began as a flight attendant for vegas
based allegiant airlines that lasted for
four years the yoke inside the airplane
moves with the ailerons covett happened
followed by a divorce the single mother
of two sees the opportunity during that
time i thought okay what is going to be
my next step in life
so
i really just thought being a flight
attendant isn't my end game and i was
like all right i think i think it's time
to take the leap
danielle began flight school in 2020 she
has her private pilot's license she's
working on her instrument rating and
hopes to become a certified flight
instructor by year's end
the training doesn't come cheap and it
requires 250 hours of flight time all in
aviation flight school in henderson is
where she's getting certified president
paul sally at any given time have about
45
to 60 students that are that are going
through
to get their
licenses towards an eventual career both
paul and his wife went to college to
become pilots then september 11th
happened the airlines stopped hiring
pilots and they cut the pay and they
made it a pretty unglamorous job waiting
for the industry to recover they became
instructors eventually opening their own
flight school in 2016. it's a really
exciting way to share your passion and
then at the same time be able to make a
living at it but once they train their
flight instructors it's tough to keep
them we're hoping to you know get more
applicants in to
you know feel that
the vacuum really
the airlines are they're taking people
really really fast right now the
airlines are in a full-on hiring frenzy
due to the mandatory 65 year old
retirement age most airlines projecting
a pilot shortage over the next decade
more than 800 000 pilots will be needed
with more than two hundred thousand in
the us there are only about sixty five
thousand female pilots in the world
which accounts for nine percent of the
total out of the thirteen thousand
pilots in the u.s only nine hundred of
them are women so i'm hoping being a
woman in aviation as there's not too
many of us that that helps me
move through the ranks faster experts
say with continued efforts in education
and outreach we can expect to see more
women in the cockpit and in other higher
profile aviation roles as well there's
so much to learn danielle is up for the
challenge 1500 flight hours among other
credentials she hopes to complete this
by the time she turns 35 and has this
advice for other women don't give up if
someone tells you you can't you
absolutely can i had i have two kids i
was a single mom for most of my flight
training you can absolutely do it i work
full time i fly there's nothing stopping
you besides you so just push through it
kiersten joyce live local now
now airlines are trying to help bridge
the gap just this year united started
teaching students at its own flight
school in arizona with the goal of
training 5 thousand pilots by 2030. the
company aiming for half of that number
to be women and people of color united
even covers the cost of pilots training
up to the point of receiving their
private pilot's license